when the president arrived in Singapore
he continued a trade fight with the
American allies he met at the g7 summit
in Canada the president tweeted this
last night fair trade is now to be
called full trade if it's not reciprocal
he criticized Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau in very personal terms
saying Justin acts hurt when called out
and he added we cannot let our friends
or enemies take advantage of us on trade
any more
we should Jiang is at the White House
with the latest on that part of the
story we should good morning good
morning Gail the g7 drama unfolded after
President Trump said his goodbyes but
top economic advisors picked up right
where he left off unleashing tirades on
Prime Minister Trudeau blaming him not
only for a looming trade war but for
starting this very public fight with the
president there's a special place in
hell for any foreign leader that engages
in bad faith diplomacy with President
Donald J Trump White House trade adviser
Peter Navarro slammed Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau for declaring Canada
would retaliate for u.s. tariffs on
steel and aluminum it was an attack on
the president National Economic Council
director Larry Kudlow piled on you just
don't behave that way okay it's a
betrayal he really kind of stabbed us in
the back if you attack this president
he's gonna fight back
Cabo added timing was a factor and
President Trump refused to appear weak
before meeting kim jeong-hoon
in fact it was on a plane from the g7 to
Singapore the president announced on
Twitter the US would not endorse the
joint communique going on to call
Canada's leader meek and mild during
meetings than very dishonest and weak
polite were reasonable but we also will
not be pushed around
the fresh tension unfolded at the end of
a weekend that looked promising filled
with happy photo ops and warm handshakes
after intense working sessions German
Chancellor Angela Merkel said an assault
on America half the presidents reversal
via tweet is sobering and a bit
depressing the decision to break from
their agreement is drawing criticism
from lawmakers Republican Senator John
McCain tweeted to our allies Americans
stand with you even if our president
doesn't the EU and Mexico have also
promised to retaliate for those u.s.
tariffs even though the president has
warned it would be a mistake of course
this conflict comes when he could use
the full support of US allies heading
into that historic summit with Kim Norah
all right we show Jane thank you